الاحتلال قبل قليل قام
باستهداف مبنى جمعيه السلامه هنا في
جباليا البلد مما ادى لوقوع عدد من
الشهداء والاصابات من المنازل المجاوره
لهذه
الجمعيه ايضا حجم الدمار كبير جدا في هذا
المكان شباب
طبعا مازالت عمليات البحث مستمره عن بعض
المفقودين هنا تحت ركام هذه
المنازل نشاهد حجم هذا الدمار في
المكان سمعت دوي انفجار كبير في المنطقه
وقامت فاذا به في احد المؤسسات الخيريه
التي ترعى الايتام والاطفال وترعى الناس
الفقراء الجمعيه فارغه فيش فيها شيء كان
للاسف الاصابات والقتلى والشهداء كلهم من
الناس الجيران واللي حواليها والناس
المحيطه بها وهيزي منظر زي ما انتم شايفين
هي
الدور هي الدور الجمعيه اللي هي مؤسسه
عسكريه وهذه بيوت كلها بليانه اطفال ونساء
وال الضرر كله في البيوت المجاوره الدور
كله في البيوت المجاوره لم يقتصر فقط على
الجمعيه لحتى الان نقل يمكن اكثر من 20
اصابه شهيد وقتيل وجريح الدفاع المدني
طبعا مشغول فكل القصف البيت ورا الثاني
كمان جيران هنا في اول معسكر جباله كان
قصف فالدفاع المدني مش لا لا هنا ولا شمال
ولا
يمين بع من تحت يا بلاش بولع
قوي خذ منه تطل يا حارس يا
عم يا بلال
بلالو احمد
احمد عثمان اه عثمان على
المستشفى اه اه شف
كما نشاهد هنا الاهالي يحاولون اطفاء
النار المشتعله في المكان بهذه الامكانيات
البسيطه لا
يتوفر السيارات للدفاع المدني هنا شمال
غزه
هكذا هو المشهد هنا في جباليا البلد بعد
استهداف طائرات الاحتلال لهذه الجمعيه
الخيريه التي تقدم المساعدات للمواطنين
مما ادى لوقوع عدد من الشهداء والاصابات
من المنازل المجاوره انس الشريف الجزيره
شمال غزه